[Music]
you breathe in about 17,000 times per
day it's a process you rarely think
about but behind the scenes a huge
coordinated effort is playing out your
vital organs the gut brain bones lungs
blood and heart work together to sustain
your life by delivering oxygen to
tissues throughout your body most of our
cells need oxygen because it's one of
the key ingredients of aerobic
respiration that's the process that
produces a molecule called ATP which our
cells use to power their many incredible
functions but getting oxygen throughout
our bodies is a surprisingly difficult
task gas enters cells by diffusing in
from their surroundings and that only
happens efficiently over tiny distances
so for oxygen to reach the cells within
our bodies it needs a transportation
network this is where our 20 trillion
red blood cells come in each one
contains about 270 million oxygen
binding molecules of hemoglobin which is
what gives blood its scarlet hue to make
these cells the body uses raw materials
that become available from the food we
eat so in some ways you could say that
oxygens journey through the body really
begins in the gut here in an amazing
display of mechanical and chemical
digestion food gets broken down into its
smallest elements like iron the building
block of hemoglobin iron is carried
through the cardiovascular system to the
body's hematopoietic tissue this tissue
is the birthplace of red blood cells and
it can be found enclosed within our bone
marrow cavities the kidneys regulate our
levels of red blood cells through the
release of erythropoietin a hormone
which causes marrow to increase
production our bodies churn out roughly
2.5 million red blood cells per second a
number equivalent to the entire
population of
so that oxygen that makes it to the
lungs will have ample transportation but
before oxygen can even reach the lungs
the brain needs to get involved the
brain stem initiates breathing by
sending a message through your nervous
system all the way to muscles of the
diaphragm and ribs this causes them to
contract thus increasing the space
inside the ribcage which allows the
lungs to expand that expansion drops
your lungs internal air pressure making
air rush in it's tempting to think of
our lungs as two big balloons but
they're actually a lot more complicated
than that here's why the red blood cells
in the vessels within your lungs can
only pick up oxygen molecules that are
very close to them if our lungs were
shaped like balloons air that was not in
direct contact with the balloons inner
surface couldn't diffuse through luckily
our lungs architecture ensures that very
little oxygen is wasted their interior
is divided into hundreds of millions of
miniature balloon like projections
called alveoli that dramatically
increase the contact area to somewhere
around 100 square meters the alveolar
walls are made of extremely thin flat
cells that are surrounded by capillaries
together the alveolar wall and
capillaries make a two cell thick
membrane that brings blood and oxygen
close enough for diffusion these oxygen
enriched cells are then carried from the
lungs through the cardiovascular Network
a massive collection of blood vessels
that reaches every cell in the body if
we laid this system out and to end in a
straight line the vessels would laugh
around the earth several times
propelling red blood cells through this
extensive network requires a pretty
powerful pump and that's where your
heart comes in the human heart pumps an
average of about 100,000 times per day
and it's the powerhouse that ultimately
gets oxygen where it needs to go
completing the body's team effort
just think this entire complex system is
built around the delivery of tiny
molecules of oxygen if just one part
malfunctioned so would we breathe in
your gut brain bones lungs blood and
heart are continuing their incredible
act of coordination that keeps you alive
breathe out
[Music]